hello and welcome to this video is his
coverage of round two of the London
chess classics the final lack of the
world chess ture let's see what happened
in round 2 i'm going to start with them
on paper most interesting game of the
round let's see John okay now it is
loaded cards and with white the world
champion playing koala with black yeah
if we look back like one year it was
clear that koalas the toughest
challenger of the world champion buy
rating he had a excellent couple of
month at the end of 2014 corona did but
nowadays both players ratings have
dwindled a little bit yeah kawana lost
like 50 60 points from his highest
rating in cars and also dropped a couple
of points but still of course come on as
one of the most serious challenges to
the world champion so let's see what
happened in this game and unfortunately
we got the bill in defense well I
understand why they do it I'm still
don't I still don't have to like it it's
irvin very often not leading to the most
exciting of games and yeah cousin most
of the time plays d3 now this kind of
slowish setup nowadays however or no not
nowadays in this game he went for
castles and and played hookie one and
this is in fact even less interesting
than the endgame here on in many cases
we get to the structure examined in this
game 96 95 okay why does threatening
some stuff on the e-file so like blocks
it white goes back that bishop is not
doing much 1b5 and it is hanging and now
we get this as well most of the time
Black need some
and a little bit of regrouping but he
gets in d5 and then we get to this kind
of structure sometimes we get it with
the pawns being back on c 2 and c 7
which would be like 121 the french
exchange structure and here we have it
with the sea pawns played yeah white
doesn't really have any good alternative
to taking i mean you don't have you
don't try to know how to develop
otherwise as the night only 3 is not
exactly well well posted so we had the
streets now and well this structure is
very unexcited white is a little bit
ahead in development he's got the rook
on the e-file already and Bishop f4 out
but it is not enough to claim anything
yeah this Bishop f4 Bishop b5 this is
kind of logical as blacks Bishop is
always looking at this pawn so trading
this off make sense it's not like
playing for a draw or anything by
trading even more just the logical move
it's just that this position doesn't
really offer any any hope for an
advantage this is a so-called REM
structure the 2d pawns like a double
isolated pawn structure where those two
pawns are ya facing each other in the
middle but it doesn't have any
characteristics of an isolated pawn
because there is no o half-opened e-file
yeah that would lead to some attack on
this pawn it just completes symmetry and
in many cases also complete draw here um
however white is it a little bit a
little bit quicker the rook is only five
so it's a very risk cray very risky way
of playing and Jack we see how it
continues why does the first to make
some pressure on d5 but Kerala is
playing this I think Evan perfectly well
he comes the pawn with the Queen
Bishop b5 yeah and now he goes from an
active approach they are not defending
on the porn passively there are a couple
of possibilities black can also do this
for example but hear something like
let's say movie one threatens made but
should be six and then going back it's I
mean it's not great yeah it's absolutely
not great for white but here you can
imagine why it maybe being a little bit
quicker on the C file and so on it's
it's very little but he decided for an
active approach she went played Queen to
be six and this idea just giving up the
porn for activity is well known from
some lines of the Petrov defense that
are kind of similar ends in nature yeah
why it takes the pond and now blacks a
black gains a little bit of time a six
the ship back we should be six and we
see that like has this counter play
against the two pawns this is a mate
threat but g6 of course defends it also
introduces the idea Bishop f5 and here a
black I think has no problems whatsoever
white has a hard time to defend the
pawns in the first place so the way it
went I think was the relatively and best
choice cars in return that be to pawn
and yeah set is hope hopes on no one is
deep on route 8 yeah it's it's important
to take note that if white takes this
this if black takes this that things can
be a little bit uncomfortable if the
White Queen gets to control that
diagonal it's probably not not brilliant
but this kind of idea can be problematic
so putting the rook on the aid makes
lots of sense d 6 for example now if you
would take here then queen d 4 is
absolutely yeah it's a huge problem for
black
you have this this issue that you cannot
take this pawn for example let's say
queen a3 the Aquino III is probably
probably not working at all something
like this is a big big problem 26 loses
to this tactic this is important getting
allowing whites to go to deform is
simply not a good idea he just played
rugby 7 it looks a little bit scary that
move because it allows rupee aid but
black has the g7 square for the king and
this is a this is very safe the black
queen controlling that diagonal is very
very crucial the NTA cousin he tried a
little bit but ultimately it wasn't
doing much on f4 yeah it did weakens a
lot and ultimately led to the perpetual
that we were heading heading for but
it's very difficult to do anything
without the move either because well the
queen is very strong on d5 is just in
the middle of the board and you're also
tied to that point so you cannot freely
move them rook and queen it is just a
draw ish position check yeah white one
the rook but of course jack here we go
and this is a perpetual white has no way
of getting out of justice was and check
translate those moves and it is a draw
yeah here we check have another check
coming or why I can also go here but
then you get that check here and again
there is check check again there is no
escape so at the end the draw not the
most exciting of games with some yeah it
is very difficult against this this
burnin burnin defense in the in the room
it's a it's a huge problem for the e
four players on that this line is so am
exceptionally solid
for black so yeah it's difficult on the
very top level on an amateur level it's
not so much of an issue because the
Berlin defense is not very popular on
the amateur level quite surprisingly yet
it hasn't really caught up there it mean
lots of amateur players they rather want
more exciting games but still if you
like somewhat yeah dry ish positions um
it's basically that I till opening to
play okay so let's go for the next game
to pile of greesh oak and there's a
reason why I'm going for that because
it's the same opening and it's a yeah a
case of yet getting getting rid of those
getting rid of those games so here d3
was played not the end game that we saw
in there in the game in round one where
Nakamura had to had black against i
think it was Grisha right was Greece
York Nakamura where they played the
endgame here dear three is played and
black now and get some yeah the good and
solid development that we are yeah used
to from the Berlin it's three and now a
six yeah many many possibilities black
can also play a set up based on 97 that
has been popular recently but a six is
of course a normal move yeah do part of
decides to decides to take them oh yeah
that cannot trouble black that much but
it's difficult to get somewhere with
other tries as well okay this is of
course the normal move but then black
goes b5 something like this and possibly
even a quickie t5s bit zone is on it's
also nothing nothing special for white
um okay the capture and castles and now
we should go with rookie eight rookie
one at age 6 h-6 is a bit more bit of a
more restrained move it anticipates
a further night f1 with Bishop g5 ideas
um he had played a d5 in an earlier game
in two thousand what is that 12 or 13 I
didn't it didn't save the game reference
i just looked it up that that was played
i was playing against Carlton and
counting 1 a nice game down with the etx
Queen takes Knight b3 and further
brother mc4 was played and Bishop b3
White was a little bit better than and I
think in this great game agree shock
simply had yeah he had to basically
looked at this and decided that it's a
wise decision just to keep the pawn
structure as it is and not change it so
much this is a very a decent idea it
seems it's not so easy for white to make
a clear suggestion what you should do as
opening up the position is of course
something you have to consider carefully
as black as got the two bishops so
normal regrouping Bishop to d7 and
Bishop e3 and now queen bee 8
interesting maneuver but why not tap the
queen is looking at this added Bishop if
white would take you can very nicely
take with the Queen and use the B file a
little bit and something like c5 coming
next and black should be very ok so
Queen d2 yeah black better takes it
before white is thinking about
sacrificing on age 6 and now a five-year
c5 was also possible yeah we already see
that this is a super super solid kind of
position do you form cakes and now queen
before that's an important resource that
black asses square on before for the
Queen and sillies got the B file that
sets rather rather important if you look
at the pawn structure in the center one
thing is important on the
and is that this Center looks nice but
it is difficult to advance it yeah if
white goes for some kind of e five black
is happy to take the d 5 square with the
night and playing d 5d 4d fire from
white and is yeah almost never possible
SS clues where it's covered even if it
possible from a technical point of view
it doesn't really help much as black
heads to c5 for example so the center is
not really a big asset in this position
and black has said counter play on the
bee farm be three cakes cakes and a for
now this is the counter play that I was
talking about and why it has to be a
little bit cautiously already something
like before it's not a good idea as a
three is isolating that pawn and it can
easily be attacked with with the rooks
here white is probably somewhat
struggling already not a great idea but
a three is very safe now why it is
threatening before with the sound
structure I mean threatening human sense
of yeah improving the position a little
bit it's not like black would be lost or
so but black rather wants to take and go
here yeah getting this counter play
going and it seems like something is
going to fall this hangs and if the
night is coming to f3 to cover it back
here then evo is falling but topalov did
a good calculation jockeys
counter-attacking on b7 and now after
Luke takes Knight f3 black rook has to
move again and now why take c7 so we
have somewhat yeah a pretty pretty
substantial exchange operation going on
and rook c8 now is again it's the check
the best move and 85 now trades down the
rest of it this is how it
check yeah this is how it ended with a
draw yeah that opening is rarely leading
so some to some excitement and yeah I'm
always thinking about those people who
claim our you have to play one year for
four exciting chest well here you get
some exciting chess yeah anyway its own
it's a bit of a bit of a shame as a
strong word but it's a it's kind of
unattractive sometimes to watch those
games but I totally understand why the
professional players do that with black
I mean what I don't understand is why
the white players keep trying is it
regardless yeah time to learn something
else may be many many a year for players
now switch to to 2d 493 or other ideas
at least in as the occasional weapon if
they suspect the other guy of playing
the villain but yeah here both cards an
end to parlor from tried okay you never
know if they go for the bill in with
black I mean it's not like Cara wanna
and we should do that all the time but
yeah why players it seems them don't
have any any idea against this opening
what to what to do in terms of putting
putting some pressure okay so next game
is gary with white against Micky Adams
give me the only winner of the first
round and he is playing the the local
guide but okay Adams is a world-class
player so it's not like he's a complete
outside of him yeah we've got the NIMS
oh yeah gary is also a catalan player
but here he goes for the names oh and
Adams plays d5 this was to be expected
this is his main move and get a couple
of interesting games in the recent month
with one particular line that I am to
recommend to my students quite a bit
this is this line takes takes Bishop g5
age 6
inch for and then c5 dc5 and castles
this is a line that was virtually
unknown until yeah that they last year
when Adams played it a bit and black
place like Bishop is 697 and rook c8 is
a very active piece play and seems to be
very okay so give it avoided that and
went a three Jake stakes yantian Adams
somewhat surprisingly goes for the move
94 not that this is a unknown move it is
one of the main lines but in most games
nowadays black goes for castles and then
plays something like this with very good
equalizing chances as well nims alyssa
is a very good opening after all yeah
this however is played NC 5 this is some
someone who delight but also a good one
and takes in 96 the thing is black has a
huge development advantage both nights
out and the only develop pieces of white
queen um yeah Knight f3 Jack Queen a
five chick bishop t2 yeah here black has
a choice he can play this move or I can
take on the tooth i'm not mistaken this
is also possible txtx and take see I
think in both cases Black has very
decent chances of equalizing and termina
this this was played in the actual game
d takes yeah black can also try d 4 i'm
a leaf but this is a bit more risky as
white as stuff like before and Queenie 7
and now it's an idea to just let black
take here and play this position now
White has more space and sometimes he's
got ideas like c5 and some some nice our
posts for the night this is the more
sound move let's say and
very understandable here in Adams case
he wants to have a sound solid position
with black he has some he's playing in
this tournament um with that unlucky
pairing a number that gives him two
blacks to start with so in this field of
yeah over this pool of sharks let's say
if you play two drawers with black at
the beginning it's pretty good so play
solid is good so castles reform queen
batteries so we should be three gaining
a little time and quincy three this is a
good move i guess quincy three it has
this idea to play b5 and ask this night
where the seven yeah intending to go on
this is especially relevant here where
98 it has to be played and this looks a
little bit uncomfortable so Adams played
a six this is not a decision to be taken
lightly because you we can unlock this
square and geary is very quick in
occupying that and well first glance and
white looks to be better here night on
b6 is very annoying on the other hand
black got this regrouping in and this is
some something that very often his own
is this it's somewhat underestimated
let's say that Bishop maneuver Bishop
see ad 78 it looks very passive but what
it does is it sort of coordinates black
blacks position quite well the bishop
only eight is not hindering any other
piece it's just sitting there and the
rooks can usually they can go to da head
and see a this is not possible he has
the night on b6 is so annoying but at
least the rooks are connected and all
the other pieces are decent quite often
you can bring this bishop later to c 6
and as I said it looks good for Wyatt
but if we see how the game continued to
nine eight seven we quite quickly see
that black also has these ideas Bishop
c6 is is there sometimes not be five or
B should be five and it doesn't look
like white is got anything much giving
went a for now looking at this square so
that nothing comes to be five but now
Queen d6 was played now this is just
occupying the D file and preventing
anything like group d 1 yeah white can
also not easily play this now what did
you do actually and that's a joyous um
why cannot play something like that
easily it doesn't doesn't lead to much I
mean Queen takes before it's no good
because here black has a huge problem
with these roofs but black and return
here and now attack this pawn this is of
course the drawback of that a phone
booth that before is weakened but ok
white wanted to make any wanted to make
some kind of progress now it's your
promise plate queen is seven and here we
have a situation where black is are now
ready to play a look to the C file or
possibly knight c6 attacking this porn
so give you went here and we had this
repetition so very unexcited game but i
guess that sometimes just happens if a
very again where his solid opening is
chosen and black in this case is
defending very very precisely i think a
six was a strong actually yeah it's to
take some it takes some some class to
decide okay i'm going to let you go to
that be six square but it is not that
terrible and it really seems to be it
looks so awful to allow the night there
but this setup is pretty okay for black
hair he's got that night a seven idea
and then
can activate himself this is the sign of
a really strong player that yet your
lower sometimes things that look that
look a little bit strange but they are
not that they're difficult in fact to
neutralize if you have planned it
precisely beforehand so on a good game
member adamz I know it's just the
20-something move draw but if you you
have to appreciate how difficult is
sometimes they're with black and a good
job man take him to to make that very
very sound draw okay let's go to a roni
an island and see what we got here got
the raw goes in here there's also one of
the topic alliance in modern top-level
chest there goes in defense of the
Queens gambit in fact both players have
fun have played this open against
opening against one another a couple of
times and with both colors yeah we also
had games are not with wide against the
wrong y and here also pretty recently um
so what is the wrong yarn I'm coming up
with now what does he have prepared and
it is the exciting move we should be too
okay now came just making a little bit
of fun here this is the kind of move
that looks super inoffensive yeah like
what is that the main idea I guess is
that the main lights are kind of stale
at the moment term as well so it's a try
at getting something just something else
and play a game um it shouldn't trouble
black so much but on the other hand I
mean it is just a game that is going to
be played c5 and a three-year white gets
this Bishop am as we are accustomed to
in the in the Rogozin or in the news Oh
type of openings but with nida form
Black is quickly making sure that he
gets the the bishop back
he took him into politics yay upon takes
is the far more interesting choice than
Queen takes after Queen takes black will
probably capture and here we have a
situation where if white takes with the
e porn the isolated queen porn position
here is probably rather comfortable for
black because we already have some
pieces traded and set up like bishop
here and maybe Knight to f6 looks very
very okay for black I mean white can
play that position it's not like white
is in bad shape but it's very yeah it's
not promising much taking away the pawn
is more interesting as the porn
structures strengthened in the center on
the other hand of course there are some
weaknesses now on the queenside 97 looks
normal Bishop d3 and h 6 h-6 looks like
a normal move but it seems that uh non
term was a bit critical about that in
them in the later analysis and we see
later why that is it's an idea that is
known from many Queens gambit positions
or a concept let's say why this move on
might have a drawback we could have
played g6 or maybe just Knight to f6 its
own it's the alternative that he had we
will see later why h6 might be an issue
I don't think it's something substantial
really but it's some interesting concept
to know it was looking quite normal I
think Knight to f6 c4 black is gaining
some space and output is not only for
and a for gaining some space here on the
queenside 96 and wide went here around
here can maybe a talk about why h6 can
be an issue sometimes the problem can be
that our can also do it here here this
move was played the 95 idea is the thing
if black has the
back on h7 just imagine the pawn being
back on age seven then you can pretty
easily play f6 and kick that night out
from me five what basically has to go
back to a 3 nothing happens I mean he
probably wouldn't have played 95 in the
first place with a porn back there if
you go f sexy em you have seriously
weakened your light square cm and this
is something that can be a problem
long-term especially because of those
weaknesses they are around the king and
that age 6 move is this theme it's
happening quite a bit also in the
exchange variation of the of the Queens
gambit for example if we go back to to
move one so that we have just want to
show the general concept if black is
playing age six in any of those
structures he has to be aware that
whenever white put something only five I
just show the general idea like this
let's say okay I know that it's not it's
not perfect David this is not as
theoretical I know anything but
something like that if you imagine this
here in other cases black might be able
to move that night and play of six and
here this is simply not possible as the
light squares are so much weakened
having played age six is a pretty big
disadvantage in comparison to the
position with the night back here if the
night is back on the haul is back on h7
then black might play 9 f8 that night
back a play of 6 and with age 6 plate
this is the difference so this little
pond would
d quite a substantial yeah subtlety so
back to the game yeah I think that
aronia probably should have tried 95
here and then see what happens let's say
um white ear looks to be a little bit
more comfortable as he at least has this
idea of playing some f3e for later not
easy to get in under under perfect
circumstances but it is an idea at least
and yeah white on the other hand a black
on the other hand cannot do that much as
I said f6 is difficult to play and you
mostly have to have to sit end in wait
it's not easy also to prepare something
on the queenside as Queen B form and a5
this kind of pressure here somewhat
annoying why does a little bit better
here but rookie one was played and after
Bishop f5 this trade now was unavoidable
and here the worst is definitely over
one reason is that now a 95 move is less
critical as f6 it's not a big problem
now as the Queen's are traded yeah those
slides squared witnesses they have those
have this long-term problematic
characters especially if there are
Queens on the board which is not the
case here anymore and here also note how
good this is an idea it covers this it
looks at this and pretty much ties the
whole position together and we had a
couple of motion but you can already
guess that more this also ends in a draw
yeah there's really no headway to be
made it sometimes feels like okay after
move 30 you draw already shouldn't they
continue and fight and whatever it's
very difficult to to suggest something
here if you go away from this this is
status quo that you have you're probably
damaging your position yeah it's
one of those cases where I think yeah
there are those those ideas and of
giving like three points for win and so
on this is all nice and good but
sometimes a draw is just what is right
in a position it's just nothing to be
done about it if you feel bad about that
you have to think about other ideas I
think then then three points for when
they had this in the London chats
classics once more than once and it it
never really had any effect on having
more wins just just doesn't work okay so
four games four drawers and let's go for
the fifth game Nakamura with right
against MBL are you kidding me no I'm
not this is exactly what was played
Nakamura one of the most aggressive
players around goes for an e3 set up
here against MBL snide f6 g6 what is the
idea there is an idea it's not it's not
just like some lame opening and the idea
is that um mvl is a huge green products
for expert and nakamura had a specific
idea here Bishop g7 C for this line is
actually um quite popular in recent
years I mean within with some limits
yeah it's not like it's a whole the rage
but it is seen sometimes in the indie
games of the top players um because they
don't do any managed to find anything
against the gruene trout and here if
black wants to play gruene felt like d5
the point is that white is taking night
eggs and now he's able to play you for
ok this is III and d4 it's two moves
that's all good it doesn't look very
dangerous but what it does is black now
has to move the night again he cannot
kept you on c3 there is no night to
capture and this position seems to be a
little bit more comfortable
white because the c5 move is also
somewhat difficult to accomplish quite
often white will get like a bishop here
and one Bishop here and there is some
control over c5 with the Knights traded
on C 3 C 5 is very easy to play but this
is not so easy here so a typical
Greenfield approach is somewhat
discouraged now Bishop e2 for the same
reason you don't go Knight c3 if you
play Knight c3 black again can go d5 and
now he has something to take ya now e4
is just pretty ridiculous idea it's a
gruenfelder tempo down so this should be
2 is the point so now that after d 5 CD
595 we get exactly the idea that I had
shown before so this is not working so
what does black do he usually goes for
something with see 5 or with g6 so the
Kings Indian or some kind of being noni
invitation yeah here white goes d5 this
is the only way to to try to do
something with this opening if white
castles then black is happy to take and
play d5 and this is a little bit like at
our Queens gambit with colors reversed
or if you want a different kind of
classification it's like a pan of
variation of the caro-kann wear white
has played the completely harmless
Bishop b2 and castles so here black has
no problems whatsoever he's rather even
the more comfortable here I mean it's
equal yeah but i'd rather be black
because I know what I need to do play
against that that week pawn um so that's
not the idea d 5 is the idea ok G 693 e6
castles take stakes so we've got a
modern benoni wear white has played the
Moose III and Bishop e2 can
that'd be any dangerous hmm probably
objectively not but it's in a playable
position and it's not the goon felt so
it's a white probably got what he wanted
even though and we see that mvl has a
pretty interesting setup now up his
sleeve he plays Knight a 6 which is not
i mean the the night is going to that
square quite often in the Benoni but
there were a couple of alternatives and
Bishop g4 for example looks decent or
just rupee aid after rupee aid white is
probably doing this and then e form he's
really just playing then we know near
temple down ok 9 a-6 interesting 92 that
is the idea you want to play you for at
some point otherwise it's completely
inoffensive rupee eight and now if I
rupee eight I think that black setup
here is really quite interesting it's
not easy now for white to to play a good
move not easy at all what do you want to
play Knight c4 is blundering the e4 pawn
here so this is no good you want to go
to sea for forever to somewhat so
somehow untie this position Bishop won't
see one that cannot stay there forever
like that so what do you do you can play
some ya can cover it with the with a
piece but this is also not that great in
some cases yeah Black has a quick b5
available that b5 now as possible as the
bishop has left this triangular or
sometimes this is also an idea directly
looking at this Square and black
probably will go there and take the
bishop yeah because training a pair of
minor pieces is generally favorable for
black and the Benoni and you don't mind
you get the dark squared bishop for your
night here white probably is inclined to
go back to you too so Bishop f3 is also
no good and ok you can play some stuff
like a groupie
one and try to go back but I mean black
is going here and preparing a quick be
five so hmm I'm not sure what nakamura
did is probably the most aggressive
movie played f3 and it's logical rather
you want to play here and then somehow
develop your your Bishop and now very
direct and nothing could move by mvl use
9h five this is just looking at this
square and looking at this check and in
some case I mean if white is now playing
something okay this is rather stupid but
let's do it yeah you have to even be
aware check of ideas like that
threatening mate yeah but here what has
to play something like this to to avoid
immediate disaster and well this is
absolutely no good so black has some
concrete ideas with that yeah like a
mora went to f4 I mean it ultimately
didn't lead to something great but it's
how to suggest something else and yeah
and he just dropped back Black has
provoked a tear for move and now this
pressure is held again you cannot leave
night see form you don't want to blunder
the e4 pawn but how do you untangle this
position it feels like there's already
some pressure on white center my camera
went king age one that's the kind of a
yeah I don't know what you do move so I
do something useful and see what happens
97 and now a for ya well be 5v5
ourselves on the card so you had to do
something there and yeah black I was a
six as we probably can expect and now a
five to prevent them immediate b5 coming
however that has the drawback as well
and here it is the bishop come and the
night comes to be five and well this is
something that you really don't
to see ya now camera is in some kind of
trouble him that opening didn't didn't
go so well and there are already a
couple of yeah continuations that that
look pretty pretty bad for example if
you play something um something slow
like rookie worn out to prepare a night
move then black is going with this and
he wants to go on a chief form and it's
already so tricky that this is losing
straight away yeah it's a very
aggressive benoni mean only idea and
it's a nice way of getting checkmated
kochiya check yeah it mate mmm that's no
good nakamura ultimately decided to play
five this is this move is basically
saying okay it is kind of screwed up so
let's try to just muddy the waters like
took that pawn of course and now night
c4 why does freeing himself this way I
think it's a good practical decision if
you just sit around there and have no
active idea whatsoever it's from you're
going to end well so just do something
active look at five a bit of a funny
spot for the rook but it is just a good
a good active square and there is no
easy way for y to make use of it I mean
what are you going to do something like
g4 oops check yeah something simple like
that is not work yeah this was played by
oh and i can wear other ideas so maybe
go over to g3 and attack the rook and
yeah here um MBR goes form a very
interesting decision and it's a its
leading to a black advantage it's just
that there were a couple of interesting
moves here black for example also i can
tell you what he did first
he and he just took that Bishop the
sacrificing the exchange and it's it's
not a bad move it's just that he had
alternatives um some moves suggested by
the engines for example on night h5 and
94 freeing that bishop for example night
h5 can be can be pretty interesting and
to explore yeah what is wyd supposed to
do again if he goes gee for it's going
to get killed quickly the rook is
hanging and there is 94 the threat note
that White's position is entirely
uncoordinated this is lost straight away
oops I'm sorry night h5 was the thing
yeah 23 years looking like the toughest
defense and now maybe allowing some g4
move yeah but black has ideas he can go
queen age for for example that was the
idea of moving the light Queen to h4 190
form it's also interesting choice
getting it was 94 yeah my analysis
versus this and and this is also an
interesting way to play getting this
into the mix and now threatening queen
age for black is also I think better in
this position an interesting point is
set after g4 there is the move Queen
edge form with the very computer ish
point that after this we should be five
is very strong it's a pretty pretty hard
to hit to to believe but what is the
idea now if white for example and takes
here black is going to recapture
something like let's say this just
normal-looking moves Black has this MDM
this is the idea Bishop b5 now
threatening made on h2 and there's this
threat as well it's quite funny white is
just losing him there are a couple of
very interesting complications that were
also possible with night h5 also Knight
g4 it was a very
critical moment of this game but what
mvl did is also good for black so it's
not really criticism just pointing out
alternatives Luke takes f3 here is not
helping white because Bishop g4 is
strong after rook move now something
like this there's 94 black wins
immediately this is also why he took her
and took with the pawn Ruger three
didn't didn't help at all so Bishop here
and Andrew p1 and 25 this was certainly
the position that the black play had in
mind when he gave away the exchange on
f3 Black now has two pawns for the
exchange he's got a very active pieces
why it is still in some disarray is not
coordinated the rook is still on a one
and he's got two bishops and he also has
a very very nice regrouping that we're
going to see shortly nida form teams
takes and now Bishop d7 I think he
probably also anticipated this idea that
you will get to the c6 square where this
Bishop will be a fantastic piece yeah
Black is still on a lot better we should
be three bishops e6 kingi too yeah
interesting here then the engines here
give 94 is a very good option and after
agree that seems to be very strong for
black um here max implied rook e8 which
is not bad but this is it seems even
more powerful attacking f3 and if white
takes this pawn is pretty strong Black
has also get some some nice ways of
increasing the pressure for example if
yeah I mean white cannot take this is
the first that we should mention night
h5 is very strong
so white has to play some some other
let's say Knight b6 at least putting
this on a safe square then known black
go just go up the aid and support that
porn again two pawns the total Bishop a
ir two bishops against two nights and a
very good coordination it seems that
black is in great shape but it was a
choice of of many continuation that all
look good so it's not not easy to play I
mean it's easy to play in a way that you
don't feel very young yeah under much
pressure is black because you just have
a choice of good things but it's tough
to to select the best one so g5 and ng
for that was his idea with ruki aid yeah
fighting for the light squares here and
getting some kind of night check-in 95
and this should be 5 and group g1 each
one there were a couple of alternatives
but I don't want to spend an hour on
that on that game age 5 and now I think
if Mike and Warren okay look 81 this um
he's still worse but it's it's a game
it's it's the very interesting he goes
h3r ever and it seems that this move
should ultimately lose however the
reason why it is lost is yeah it's kind
of inhuman to expect them somewhat to
find that we'll see now what it was this
was played by by mvl but what he could
have done is he could have taken on f3
and this is a very fearless move of
course as bishop age 6 is in them in the
position so what is it Bishop age 6 what
is the point yeah black can check check
this is a point King back here and the
amazing resource that black asses you
can play King 287
and now after Bishop takes black has the
move Bishop e6 and this whole sequence
is as I said completely inhuman um what
is the point the threat is bishop age
three and white cannot defend against
that he's a hole look up I mean almost
and black has three pawns but he's a
rock up but he can not defend against
bishop takes a three also note that I
mean like okay can can go here and but
then we just take here and now black has
three points and he's got tons of
threats this pawn is a super dangerous
there's the f6 idea and so on so here
why does out of ideas he has no moves he
cannot move this night for example as c4
hangs and yeah let Bishop e3 ATM that's
lost it just lost now so I mean like
here check this is happening it is lost
but who's going to calculate that very
difficult again this is this whole
sequence i have but can also go to III
by the way but this is also not helping
and f2 and again it's a look for the
moment but why does not going to survive
something like this and now this is just
terrible there are tons of ideas like
check here check here and why this is
why this losing this is something that
the engine says like- to where you say I
we could have seen that but well we have
to be still wear that yeah humans are
not computers you cannot calculate all
kinds of crazy variation that the engine
seized immediately he did this and this
is also not looking too bad of course
yeah Black has some so many good choices
but objectively speaking just if you
look at let's say pure pure mathematics
that the engine is presenting you then
she takes f3 I would have won the game
so this is what he was going for but in
comparison it is just yeah far less
convincing especially if you think about
white skin position now what's king is
quite safe there are a couple of pieces
traded and white should have no big
issue in in holding this this end game
in fact the way it went jack is rather
black who needs to be a little bit
cautious that and the White rooks don't
get too active okay I don't want to look
at this too much it seems that the
moment when and black got this set up it
he could be relatively satisfied the
night is covering this the age porn is
not going anywhere and he activated his
rook now this is probably just a draw
there's nothing a great dead white can
try them jack they did a couple of times
then agreed to that draw so this was the
only somewhat interesting game of the
round and probably spoiled some spoiled
opportunities form for for black I think
especially G takes f3 would have won the
game even though this is something that
I don't think even the absolute best
players in the world would be a yeah
frustrated or anything that they
couldn't figure that one out I'm still a
little bit of a disappointment mvl I
think had a very good position and yeah
chances to win but couldn't couldn't
make it work at the end ok so this round
wasn't so exciting some somewhat lame
games but I think the final game Ian
Nakamura Rashida groffen yeah was a nice
compensation for some other not so
exciting games yeah make sure to watch
also coverage of round three and if you
are a member of them as you see the
internet chess club you can also watch
the live commentary of the ICC which is
provided
for round 3 by last boo Hansen the
Danish Grand Master together with me so
if you like to watch me or listen to me
doing live commentary and you are on the
ISS see make sure to join in for round
three it has some Anand against Magnus
Carlsen so do all of them let's not
screw it up 15th and 16th world champion
ok guys thanks for watching